thank you
[Music]
the top stories live from the Sky News
City Studio
Ryanair predicts its busiest ever summer
as it returns to profit
record asking prices for properties as
confidence in the housing market grows
NatWest continues its return to private
ownership as the treasury reduces its
stake by one and a quarter billion
pounds
plus the Kia store material at Labor's
plans for the future of the NHS this
hour
[Music]
good morning this is in King live in our
business and economic news from the
Heart of the City Ryanair this morning
predicted a strong summer after
returning to full year profits Europe's
biggest Airline expects to run more than
3 000 flights daily this summer its
largest ever schedule the news came as
Ryanair reported a pre-tax profit of
1.44 billion euros for the year to the
end of March that compared with a loss
of 429.8 million euros during the
previous 12 months Ryanair carried 168.6
million passengers during the year that
was up 74 on the same period a year
earlier I've been speaking with
ryanair's Chief Financial Officer Neil
sorahan
ah look I think it's too early to say
whether anything is to the downside or
the upside
um we we've got a big fuel Bill coming
at us over the course of the next year
but based on the robust bookings into
the summer uh Ferris training ahead
where we're costly optimistic that we
will cover that additional Fuel and then
grow profits modestly year on year I
mean that's underpinned by a really
strong balance sheet and a car space
that's second to none
yes you mentioned that your few bills
going to be a billion euros High during
the course of the year you're 15 unhed
which is uh caught me bit by surprise I
mean your hedging is kind of the Envy of
the industry normally was up by accident
or by Design
uh hedging is something that we do to
smooth out costs over time you know we
don't speculate on on the oil Market
what we are doing now though which is a
bit different to the past is that that
85 is a combination of swaps which is
fixed about 75 and the balance which are
options which is affected the insurance
policy if we see a spike in the market
so we've got about 25 variability if the
market was to to dip uh but equally
we've covered out the worst case
scenario on the upside with the the
calls looking at the year just ended you
put on something like 300 new routes
during the year which were the ones that
surprised you most in how well they did
and which perhaps were more
disappointing
well to be honest none of them are
disappointed us um they're going
exceptionally well uh domestically is
particularly strong but outbound as you
would expect uh some destinations from
the UK Ireland uh Germany et cetera
continue to be very strong and very well
booked Central and Eastern Europe is
going exceptionally well for our Charter
Airline buzz and you know they've added
extra capacity uh this summer but pretty
much across all of the network we've
seen big opportunities and strong
demands you're putting on this summer
3000 flights daily How concerned are you
about possible industrial disputes by
air traffic controllers
well very uh we've had 57 days of French
ATC strikes already this year and you
know a million of our customers are
concerned enough to have signed our
petition which we will now uh deliver to
the the EU in advance of this and
building on the operation resilience
that we had last summer we've recruited
to higher numbers than we've ever had
before and so that in the events that we
do have delays on the day we've got lots
of standby traffic or sorry a lot to
stand by uh cabin crew and Pilots for
the next days there's no cancellations
for our passengers
controls enter again to make sure that
we can handle everything and you know
we'll continue to deliver the industry
leading on Time Performance but uh the
fact that uh flights over flying France
uh during days of strikes uh are are
impacted means that you know passengers
will unfortunately be impacted by a
French ATC
you mentioned their recruitment you've
taken on an extra 3 000 crabbing crew
during the year just ended what what are
your recruitment plans for the current
Financial year
yeah we're already recruiting for the
summer of 2024. we tend to look about 12
months uh ahead as you said three
thousand extra people this summer a
thousand of those were pilot Cadets uh
2000 cabin crew and you know we'll have
another thousand Pilots going through
the system this year as we grow by a
further 10 to 185 million passengers
equally would be adding on the
engineering side uh in the labs for the
back office support and and in the cabin
with the cabin crew so you know we we
take a 12-month outlook on that we're
already uh lining up new training
schools to uh you know build for the
next decade as we start to take in the
uh the max 10 aircraft and so you know
we do long-term planning in Reiner yeah
I mean this is the big news lately
you've just uh completed this
Blockbuster order with Boeing what about
uh current plans and orders that you
have in train how many new Jets will you
be expecting to receive this year from
Boeing
yeah we've got a an excessive 50
aircraft coming in uh in in this Current
financial year uh we're running a little
bit behind uh this this summer due to
the the Fastener issue that they had
with the fuselages they're catching up
on that and we think we'd be about 10
aircraft shorts uh during uh May June
and July but hopeful that that will then
get picked up into the Autumn and that
deliveries will be back on track uh
we've got 110 aircraft left in the order
book uh with Boeing on on the game
changer a200s and the last of those
should be in by December 2024 then we've
got a two-year gap before we take the
first off the max 10 aircraft in 2027.
what sort of Remedies are in place if if
Boeing's delivery slipper to all over
coming months
we're comfortable
um that they are catching up in fact we
took an aircraft in last Friday with
another one coming in today with a
further one due in this Friday so they
are catching up they are starting to uh
release aircraft from Seattle they're
getting better and faster at fixing the
Fastener issue
um but you know if there is a prolonged
delay uh if it does wrong run Beyond
kind of August uh then you know you're
going to see more of our growth moving
from the first half of the year into the
second half of the year but I would be
hopeful borrowing some other shock
um that you know we will be back on
track pretty autumn
and what about uh fairs over the coming
12 months talk to me about uh the sort
of pricing decisions that you're having
to make right now
well we we've grown huge market shares
all across Europe we've got a lot of
airports very keen to get Ryanair
capacity uh into the system as always we
remain load active yield passive which
means we'll price uh to fill the planes
but uh European Aviation capacity is
only running at about 90 to 95 percent
of pre-cover capacity so well we're at
125 of where we were pre-cover the
market hasn't caught up at the same time
uh there's huge demand for travel so the
supply demand uh narrative means that
that fares are up uh year on year and we
would anticipate that we will grow very
sufficiently to cover that extra billion
that we have on the fuel Bill and and
then grow our profits modestly year on
year fairs into the summer are tracking
ahead of where they were last year we
don't as is always the case at this time
of the year in have a huge visibility uh
into the second half of the year so it's
hard to know where fairs will go other
than we will continue to fill the planes
and price accordingly yeah
some breaking news now in the last 20
minutes it's emerged that meta the owner
of Facebook and Instagram has been fined
1.3 billion US Dollars by the European
Union's privacy Regulators for sending
user information to the United States
that's according to the online edition
of The Wall Street Journal joining me
now is our correspondent Matthew
Thompson Matthew a huge find this
it's a record fine it's the biggest fine
ever levied for a breach of the gdpr
regulations so it shows the seriousness
with which European Regulators are
taking this in terms of the dispute
itself it's long running in fact it's
been going on for the best part of a
decade effectively what meta has done in
breach of these gdpr regulations is it
regularly transfers EU users data back
to America were obviously lots of these
big tech companies are based and this uh
piece of regulatory dispute if you like
originated from a legal Challenge from
Austrian privacy campaigners who were
concerned that EU citizens data when it
was being shipped back if you like to
the US was potentially subject to the
much more stringent surveillance of
American intelligence agencies the FBI
the CIA and the like and that was in
breach potentially of EU data which as
we know is is considerably a little is
considerably stricter in terms of
protection of citizens data than the US
is at all so this has been a
long-running battle the fine is one
thing actually potentially more damaging
for Facebook is the fact that it's also
been asked by the EU Regulators to stop
within five months this transfer of data
from the EU to the US now the first
reason that's difficult is it's not
altogether clear that that's technically
possible the way Facebook's business is
set up so that's going to require some
major restructuring the second thing is
Facebook itself or meta rather we should
be calling it admitted in a call with
investors last month that if it was
asked to pause this data sharing it
could cost it something in the region of
10 of its annual advertising Revenue now
the fine is in the region of as you say
1.3 billion dollars one billion pounds
but 10 of its Global advertising revenue
is in the multiple billion so actually
in terms of the hit to the business this
could be significantly more costly to
meta what they've said in a statement
though is they've pointed to a agreement
which is in the offing between us and EU
authorities on data sharing now if that
agreement which is in advanced stages we
understand if that were to be concluded
well all of this would go away
effectively however there is a big
caveat to that which is that there are
potentially likely to be significant
challenges to this legislation possibly
in the European courts so it's by no
means a foregone conclusion that any
agreement struck between the EU and the
US would make matters problems go away
in this instance
okay thanks Matthew
asking prices for properties coming to
Market have hit an all-time high this
month that's according to Rightmove the
property portal it says the average
price of a property coming to the market
this month Rose by 1.8 percent to hit
894 pounds that's the biggest monthly
increase seen so far this year and it
Compares with the average increase of
one percent thus historically been seen
in May well joining me now for more and
this is Tim Bannister he's Right Moves
director of property science Tim welcome
to you I mean we often get a spring
bounce in activity but this is uh quite
unexpectedly strong
that's right it's a little bit higher
than we normally would expect at this
time of year 1.8 when on average they
they do go up at this time of year but
about one percent
um and I think it reflects you know that
building of confidence we've seen uh
over the course of the Year leading on
from uh what is seven months ago now
that the mini budget and the turmoil of
the last
um sort of three months of 2022. so
we've seen you know people at that point
they step back but we saw from the
beginning of this year they started to
come back uh looking for their next home
um and that's given some confidence I
think we've seen mortgage rates
stabilize um certainly at a lower rate
than they were
um back uh in October last year and
that's also contributed to this and
that's been reflecting a little bit of
confidence
um and prices
um as say up 1.8 they're actually at a
record um level at this point
this will surprise people given the
speed at which interest rates have risen
yeah I I think you know we've I was
thinking about this earlier we've had 17
months now of of interest rates going up
um so we're well into that cycle of
interest rates going up um with seven
months to say post post this sort of
term out of the midi budget so I I think
it sort of filtered through we started
to see you know we we have seen mortgage
rates in fact um come down despite the
fact that the bank of England rate has
been going up so compared to uh October
last year the mortgage rates are are now
4.56 for a 15
um uh deposit mortgage uh at that point
last year they were at sort of 5.89 that
sort of region
um so they've been coming down they've
obviously been stabilizing a bit which I
think is the key albeit at rates which
are higher than they were a year ago but
they've been stabilizing in the last um
months two months
um I think that's sort of given a little
bit of confidence that people can now
plan they understand what um to expect
obviously things can change there are
many twists and turns probably uh for
the rest of this year in inflation Still
Remains high but it's expected to come
down we'll wait and see whether that
that that comes to pass
um so there's there's still some twists
and turns but there's a little bit more
confidence and I think that's leading
through to demand
um and it's also leading through to
sellers bringing properties to the
market
um and I suppose critically even though
prices are sort of stabilizing at where
they are at the moment
um up 1.5 on where they were a year
below
um transactions are still taking place
so transactions so sold subject to
contracts where people are shaking hands
and agreeing on a sale they're down
three percent on where they were in 2019
so quite similar to the levels we've
seen in a more normal market like 2019
so transactions are taking place
um at these kind of prices
um so we're seeing a little bit of
stability a little bit of confidence
um if you'd be cautious should be
restraint
um at this point because I'll just say
this there are many things that could
happen as we as we progress through 2023
but I think it's really encouraging
Tim you've used that word confidence a
few times now I mean confidence seems to
be in the strongest Supply at the top
end of the market that's where asking
prices are growing most rapidly
that's right they're up um for the
bigger properties so uh four bedroom
detached and five bedrooms and above
that's the sector we look at top of the
ladder they're up 2.8 percent
um and you know against on average 1.8
so we think on that we would urge you a
little bit of caution there
um perhaps that's a little over
optimistic um you know if properties are
coming to the market the right price and
competitively price they are selling
um but you know in that particular
segment we've seen um you know I say
sales are um three percent below where
they were in 2019 in that segment
they're six percent below where they
were in 2019 so perhaps a little bit
overconfidence in that top of the market
um uh segment so and we'll see what
happens there whether that sort of is
tempered a little bit in the coming
months
all right Tim we've got to leave it
there good to talk to you this morning
thank you thank you
some other business news stories for you
now and the treasury said this morning
it sold another 1.26 billion pounds
worth of shares in NatWest group the
sale takes the taxpayers stake in the
lender which at its peak was around 84
down to 38.6 it's the sixth block sale
of the government's stake in the bank
previously named Royal Bank of Scotland
of course during the global financial
crisis 15 years ago well Andrew Griffith
the economic secretary to the treasury
said today's sale is another major
milestone in returning that Wester full
private ownership as promised the
government has now sold well over half
its shareholding shares of NatWest are
currently ahead by nearly nine percent
right now
almost half of medium-sized British
companies plan to delay investment plans
Following last month's increase in
corporation tax that's according to a
survey by the accounting firm BDO it
found that 46 of businesses with the
turnover between 10 to 300 million
pounds expect that the rising
corporation tax would delay investment
some 39 percent of firms questioned said
it would slow hiring or lead to job
losses well the news comes days after
Jeremy Hunt the chancellor told the
annual conference of the British
Chambers of Commerce that he wanted to
cut business taxes but warned it might
not be possible in this Autumn's budget
and the sustainable Technologies and
Industrial materials group Johnson
Matthey has signed a three-year
partnership agreement with the Norwegian
company High star to step up its
production of green or renewable
hydrogen under the agreement Johnson
Matthey will supply the company with
membrane electrode assembly is one of
the key components in the electrolyzers
used in green hydrogen production the
pair have been working together since
2021 although no figure was published
this morning concerning the agreement
foreign
[Music]
stocks in the Asia Pacific region
enjoyed a largely positive session
overnight with the nickname Tokyo
enjoying more games following
indications from the bank of Japan's
Governor that the country's Ultra boost
monetary policy will remain in place for
the time being Sydney there in the
bottom right hand corner of the screen
was the only major Market in the region
to finish lower well in Europe things
are a little bit more cautious uh this
morning ahead of developments on the U.S
debt ceiling negotiations as you can see
the Ibex in Madrid is the only
Continental European index in positive
territory right now that's not to say
there are not some gainers across the
continent and one standout feature today
is Borussia Dortmund chairs of the
German Football Club are hit by some 13
in Frankfurt that is us the club looks
set to win the German league title I'll
be the first time since 2013 that
someone other than Bayern Munich has won
the Bundesliga meanwhile the main stock
index in Greece is up by more than six
and a half percent that's after the
center-right government looks set to be
re-elected well here in London the ftse
one 100 is in positive territory
currently up a third of one percent
right now in a broad-based rally the
leading Blue Chip Gainer currently is
burberry the shares in the fashion
retailer fell by more than nine percent
on Thursday and Friday that has
evidently brought a few bargain hunters
out of the woodwork another uh Gainer
This Morning JD Sports you'll recall we
have the chief executive on the program
a week ago last week uh that is wanted
after some positive broker comment on
those results outside the footsie the
car parts maker dial lace is up another
three and a half percent that is after
portfolio managers continue to build a
position in the stock following its
recent demerger from Melrose top of the
screen there you can see Wiz air that
shares up nearly two percent right now
that seems to be in sympathy with
ryanair's very strong reports today and
the green hydrogen and ammonia
production company atom energy the
shares they're up eight percent off to
the US Energy firm Baker Hughes snapped
up a 6.6 stake on the downside as you
can see on the screen there dakara
Pharmaceuticals that's a Veterinary
farmers business used to be in the ftse
100 the shares off nine and a half
percent nearly following a profits
warning this morning on the phone
exchange markets
pretty quiet to be honest with you
Sterling more or less unchanged right
now against the dollar off a tenth of
one percent against the Greenback uh The
single currency meanwhile up at eighth
of one percent nearly against the dollar
all eyes on the U.S debt ceiling
negotiations there as for the oil price
well that sold off on Friday afternoon
and it's continued to drift a bit this
morning amid concerns over demand for
Chuck we'll look at that it's more or
less unchanged really quiet morning all
around Battle of Brent crude will
currently set you back 75 56 cents about
as I say that is more or less unchanged
joining me this morning is Eleanor
ingleby she's Deputy head of portfolio
management at atomos uh Ellie good to
see you this morning it is all about the
US debt ceiling right now isn't it the
focus is absolutely fully on that and it
sounds almost quite sensationalist to
say that the US might run out of money
however it is a very challenging time
and whilst the deadline is the first of
June they have to make a deal this week
in order to loosen that that noose
around their neck to a certain extent
yeah the fact that Biden didn't uh you
know he didn't call off his trip to the
G7 though kind of in spot I hope that
something is afoot I think so the market
seemed quite confident that they will
actually reach this deal I was reading
this morning that if they don't reach a
deal it could potentially drop the Dow
Jones by around 20 percent and certainly
we'd expect to see some indication of
that in the Futures over the weekend
yeah I mean I think the Market's uh
looking for a fairly positive start
right now actually in the U.S apart from
Metra of course that was an interesting
uh bit of news we got just then really
interesting I feel for matter they can't
seem to catch a break recently you know
the company on paper it looks very good
but they seem to be struggling to find
direction and certainly the regulation
seems to be catching up with them let's
talk about uh what's been going on in
the European market so I'm fairly
lackluster uh there today but I mean
European markets have had a reasonably
good made thus far haven't they they
have and they've been one of the
strongest Equity markets year to date
you know in double figures up around 11
in comparison to other areas which have
struggled more but I think if you look
at what's Driven that strength um year
to date it's really been the avoidance
of an energy crisis and and the
confidence that China's coming back out
of lockdown and will start spending on
luxury goods however the data on that is
a little bit shaky we're not quite
seeing the positives we might have
expected to see so be interesting to see
where European markets go from here on
yeah well I've just heard actually
talking about meta the companies just
said in the last couple of moments it's
going to appeal it's called this fine
from the European commission unjustified
and unnecessary well they've got the
legal teams to do it and certainly the
money to do it but I think that'll be a
fascinating battle to watch in court
yeah back right back to Europe though I
mean how much of this is done to
interest rate expectations do you think
the fact that the ECB kind of indicated
last time around it was going to pause
on its rate hiking we've also had some
really really good company results yeah
I think it's easy to do with that and I
think there's certainly indications that
both the third and the ECB are going to
pause and they seem to have reached that
peak of inflation which is the market is
extremely positive now further afield we
got this news overnight that Micron
which is a big U.S chip company has been
banned by China effect actively this is
huge news but also it's interesting
Micron only have around they generate
around 11 of their revenue from China
but what we're seeing though is the
ramping up of the trade War this is not
the first time this has happened and the
US has certainly banned companies before
from China and found other ways in which
they can hamper that technology
production really all right Ellie got to
leave it there good to see you this
morning thank you just to recap on that
news uh we brought you earlier in the
program meta find 1.3 billion US Dollars
by the European Commission in the last
few moments meta has said that this find
is unjustified and unnecessary and it
will be appealing we'll have more on
that throughout the morning here on Sky
News but still to come here on Ian King
live why the closure of riding schools
is threatening the UK's equine industry
don't go away
[Music]
thank you
that has happened
in minutes and now it's coming from both
sides
moving this way
[Music]
only about half a mile from the Turkish
coast and it's evident that there's the
boat seriously overcrowded this is one
of the most severe viruses in the world
I'm Alex Crawford and I'm Sky's special
correspondent based in Istanbul
got us then a lot of action going on
a lot of
you still
[Music]
we aim to be the best and the most
trusted place in news
clearly not had very much to eat at all
a lot of them extremely thin and very
frail look at her arms I can put my
entire hand round
this is the cocktail of drugs which the
doctors at this Hospital have been
giving their coronavirus patients
made for people who want Clarity in an
uncertain world
[Music]
Mother Nature is can be vicious
absolutely Savage
[Music]
I can't imagine
how much plastic is lying at the bottom
of this huge Lake
[Music]
close and personality
this is what makes the job
welcome back now more than 250 riding
schools have closed during the last five
years and the UK's equine industry is
under threat as a result that's the
warning from the British horse Society
the UK's largest equine charity which
promotes animal welfare and which seeks
to protect access to Bridal ways for
horses and their Riders it's now
launching a campaign keep Britain riding
to provide financial and practical help
for riding schools well joining me now
is James hick he's chief executive of
the British horse Society James welcome
to you what is behind this loss in
riding schools
well good morning there is many things
that are happening across the UK at the
moment and one of the key things of
course is that riding schools can't find
the staff to make sure that they can be
viable and safe places for people to
come to
more than 75 percent of writing schools
are struggling with finding staff and
the implication of that is of course
that may create writing schools to close
but as the British horse Society one of
the things that we've done is created a
career transition fund which is a
bursary we've had about 1700 people that
have come on to that there are also many
other things such as the uh costs of
insurance for example running a center
as another major cost that has to be
born
and one of the other issues that
fortunately we've been able to reverse
is around the rateable values of riding
schools but it's critical that we can
keep riding schools open not just for
the economic reasons and non-racing uh
questionism has a value of about 4.7
billion pounds to the UK economy
but it's also about health and
well-being and being able to give people
that ability to enjoy horses as we have
done for thousands of years
absolutely I should say that's Theo that
you've got with you uh right now um I
mean writing skills really are the
backbone of the rural economy in many
ways aren't they
oh absolutely you know there are
something like 1 600 or so riding
schools up down the UK
most of those are quite small businesses
but of course they have a supply chain
around them and the key thing is making
sure that they maintain a viability now
most riding schools will tell you that
they've got a wasting list of at least
50 clients so there is great demand but
the issue is having availability of the
actual places to go and there are many
riding schools up and down the country
and I'm here today at one that is a
charity and this organization here the
Cavalier Center is actually delivering
well-being benefits to disadvantaged
children for example through our
changing lives through horses program
and if these writing schools weren't to
be here many children and young people
who aren't able to access education in
the normal way may be excluded from any
type of education and the power of
horses allows them to be both educated
and also develop life skills so it's
critical that we keep Britain riding
James just to go back to the point that
you were making earlier on Staffing why
are centers suffering these staff
shortages I mean most people I know
who've been involved in ridings Hills I
mean they're extremely motivated they're
not just doing it for the money they're
doing it for the love of the horses as
well
you're absolutely right Ian there are a
whole number of reasons but what we see
is the same issues across riding schools
as we see across the broader economy
you've got pressures in terms of an
aging population
the time it takes to actually be able to
become qualified specifically to be able
to coach uh people that need to be over
high standards that takes time it takes
a lot of effort and as we see many
people perhaps don't want to have that
job it's beautiful on a day like today
but when it's winter time it's quite a
tough job but the rewards are huge
working with horses being outside
bringing great pleasure to people both
in their pleasure time but as I say more
importantly what we can see is that
health and well-being benefits of riding
is absolutely critical
absolutely it is James best of luck to
you with the campaign and uh thank you
to uh to you for keeping Theo uh under
control he's been very well behaved
hasn't he
cool lovely stuff see you again James
thank you see you
the breaking news that we can bring you
now courtesy of our city editor mark
kleiman and it concerns John Allen the
chairman of Tesco who has been reported
on Friday afternoon is stepping down
Mark what have you got
yeah that's right Ian we've got of
course that confirmation on Friday that
Mr Allen would step down as chairman of
Tesco next month following allegations
of inappropriate behavior which uh which
he strenuously uh denies what I can
reveal this morning Ian is that Mr Allen
is also now in talks to sell his 20
shareholding in a mentoring business
called uh jna mentoring Partners which
he set up with his co-founder Anna
Joseph about five years ago now he's
going to sell his 20 stake in the firm
to miss Joseph uh the price is
undisclosed and those talks are now
underway as I understand it uh the
shareholder agreement between the two of
them when the business was founded in
2018 always envisaged uh that this
transaction would take place at some
point but it's only now emerged that Mr
Allen is going to sell his stake in this
business now jna provides mentoring
services to up and coming corporate
Executives it includes a roster of very
well-known corporate figures as mentors
people like Cressida Hogg the chair of
BAE Systems and Adam Crozier the
chairman of BT group now of course Mr
Allen has already stepped down as
chairman of the house Builder Barrett
developments we know he's stepping down
next month as chairman of Tesco and he
is now in talks to sell his stake in jna
mentoring Partners now Mr Allen's
spokesman confirmed that he will remain
a mentor one of the people involved with
the business but that he is indeed in
talks to sell his stake to his
co-founder Anna Joseph
Mark I mean we should we shouldn't
really lose sight of the fact here that
uh whatever is uh being said about John
Allen now I mean he has had an
enormously distinguished career in uh
British business he's he's probably one
of the more influential figures on the
British business scene over the last
couple of decades you could say uh no no
doubt about that at all Ian uh Mr Allen
is hugely well respected uh in
boardrooms he's served on uh boards like
uh Royal Mail uh and uh Carphone Dixon's
car phone uh over the last couple of
decades he's become an influential
figure in terms of uh uh you know
Britain's
um uh British businesses approach to
politics and of course was a president
of the CBI which itself now is uh in the
spotlight in terms of its future
survival
um and uh Mr Allen uh is 74 now is
likely to bow out with these allegations
um hanging over him but as you say in an
incredible the distinguished figure over
the last 20 years in British corporate
life
all right Mark thanks for that
uh we're just going to break into the uh
business news momentarily now because uh
secure storm of the labor party leader
is about to give a speech on the NHS
let's listen him
thank you
thank you where's thank you all for
being here it is fantastic to be in
Braintree
um I've got very fond memories of this
part of the world because 16 happy years
ago I got married just down the road in
the fence so that's why it's got this
special place in my heart and almost as
good as that this is where two weeks ago
at the local elections the labor party
was back on the march in Essex
but today I'm here to speak about
something that's fundamental to the
labor party fundamental to our purpose
of working people
the NHS
just look at it
the eight o'clock scramble
the appointments missed opportunities
missed to spot the pain that turned out
to be a tumor patients who want to go
home are well enough to go home but who
have to stay in hospital for months
waiting for a care package
day long waits in a e
record numbers off work sick
people pulling their own teeth out
seven million on waiting waiting waiting
lists
and ambulances for heart attacks and
stroke victims that don't come on time
just think about that for a second
ambulances that don't come
can any of you imagine losing someone in
that way
I can't I can't and and I mean that in
every sense
I can't imagine it it shouldn't be
possible in our country but it is
a cruel Lottery of who lives and who
dies that the NHS was founded to stop
and until now until this point for 75
years it has
it's one of the greatest privileges of
being born in Britain certainly for all
of my life
the knowledge that if you get ill if you
have a serious accident
you'll get the care that you need
whatever your circumstances
not every country has a system like that
and the insecurity the fear without it
is huge
Knight Bevin the labor Health secretary
who created the NHS put it best
he said
illness is neither an Indulgence for
which people have to pay
nor an offense for which they should be
penalized
that's what we believe
and it's under threat I mean it
I don't think the NHS survives five more
years of Tory government
and people say oh well we've heard this
before the labor party is always saying
it's time to save the NHS
but I say
look squarely in the eyes of the people
who work in the NHS who serve the NHS
and ask them
speak to the working people who use the
NHS who depend on the NHS who need the
NHS
what do they say
and go to the people who believe in the
NHS love the NHS but have been forced to
buy the care they need from the private
sector listen to them
no at the next election the NHS is on
the line the conservative party that's
brought it to its knees will put it in
the ground
but mark my words
if all we do in the labor party is to
place the NHS on a pedestal and leave it
there
that's not good enough either
we've got to fix the fundamentals
renew its purpose make it fit for the
future
that's what this mission is about a new
direction for the NHS to say to the
British people vote labor problem solved
would be an insult to everyone's
intelligence
patients can see how deep the problems
go
my Approach is different
it starts with the cause
the central project
how do we serve working people
and then it asks what do we value what
do we conserve cherish and protect
the answer
a public and Universal Health System
free at the point of use paid for by
General taxation the NHS
thank you
but then it asks what do we need to
change
what are the challenges the
opportunities how can we save lives
improve lives provide more dignity
Innovation where can it be found people
how do we unlock their purpose
technology how do we make it work for us
and when you've asked those searching
questions you turn back you roll up your
sleeves or you face reality
and the reality is this
the NHS is not sustainable unless we
make serious deep long-term changes
that's my politics reform for Renewal
National missions for the common good
and NHS fit for the future
now some people will tell you it's
purely a question of money
and money is a part of it I don't deny
that like any opposition we will set out
our plans before the election unlike any
incoming government we will make
decisions based on a full appreciation
of the reality
state of our NHS and our public finances
but what's more important now I really
believe this is to show our recipe for
reform
to put forward a vision of a renewed NHS
that can make the most of the money we
invest in it
I've run a public service I know that
money makes a difference
but it only gets you so far
you can't look at the problems now and
tell me it's just about money
that's not serious
you can't ignore the fact the world has
changed that's denying the evidence
before our eyes
the British people are living longer
life expectancy in 1948 was 68. today
it's over 81. that is a good thing
but it brings new challenges
the nature of disease is different
instead of urgent and acute hospital
care
now it's more about managing chronic
long-term conditions
The Wonder of science has taught us with
ever increasing Clarity that our health
depends on how we live
mental health has stepped out of the
shadows and thank goodness
and with artificial intelligence with
personalized medicine with new vaccines
we stand on the cusp of a revolution
that could transform health care for the
better
my message today is this
Science and Technology are the game
changers this is the prize this is what
it gives us an NHS where prevention
comes first where care is closer to home
where patients have more control
so
to everyone working in the NHS today
serving on the front line
I say
thank you
without you there would be no light at
the end of the tunnel
but I also say
the walk towards that light will be hard
will feel challenging difficult
but do not doubt it's essential and that
the reward for reform will be worth it
and look don't doubt this either the
Taurus will never deliver this they
voted against the NHS right at the start
and more than once
and while they come to accept it as part
of the political furniture
in their heart of hearts they don't
believe in its Central promise for them
it's a cost not a Cause
and from that mindset Springs The Well
of their neglect the poverty of their
ambition the sticking plaster crisis
management impulse that never sees the
opportunities never addresses the long
term
it's not that they don't care
it's that they're priorities their
ideology it takes them somewhere else
200 billion pounds a year
that doesn't square with their small
state vision of Britain and that's why
we have familiar problems every year for
the last 13 years we've had a winter
crisis and every year in about February
or March
we do just enough to keep the NHS going
we breathe a bit in the summer and then
we go into the next NHS crisis the next
winter the only difference being it's
worse than the one that went before
they know what's even worse than that
the tourists underestimate the NHS
underestimate the bond between people
and service
underestimate what you can do with a
mission
that yes people go to work in EHS for a
wage of course they do
but of also because they believe in
something
this is how we go beyond the sticking
plaster mindset how we solve the crisis
and tackle the long-term challenges
I want an NHS back on its feet of course
I do
but I also want an NHS that's fit for
the future
and that requires a partnership
between people and service
that builds on what is distinctive about
the NHS as a health system
now
protect the NHS was the pandemic slogan
and we did
and in turn
it predict it protected us
so have no doubt this mission is a cause
but it's a cause that can only succeed
if we embrace the need for reform
so Labor's National mission on health
to build an NHS fit for the future
and as with all our missions we set that
Direction with clear measurable goals
goal one the next Labor government will
deliver an NHS that is there when you
need it
ambulances seven minutes for Cardiac
Arrest A E back to the four hour Target
GPS the highest satisfaction levels on
record waiting lists Down plan treatment
within 18 weeks no backsliding no
excuses we will meet these standards
again we will get the NHS back on its
feet
go to
we will improve healthy life expectancy
for all and we'll halve the inequality
gap between different regions of England
and let me explain what that means
it means we will restart a trend Britain
has come to take for granted
that to be blunt we should take for
granted
a sign of progress that generation after
generation the people of this country
are living healthier lives happier lives
and longer lives
the tourists have reversed that
that's their legacy
and look by focusing on health
inequalities we can make Britain fairer
as well
did you know
black women are four times more likely
to die whilst having a baby than white
women
in my constituency a girl born in
Highgate Hill will live 10 years longer
than a girl born in summers town
that is three miles away
my labor party won't stand by and let
that happen we've got to root these
inequalities out
and to achieve this we must Zone in on
our biggest Killers three killers which
we know are demanding questions of our
health care System
one cardiovascular diseases heart
attacks and strokes we'll get them down
by a quarter within a decade
two
cancer
we will make sure 75 percent of all
cancer is diagnosed at stage one or two
let me tell you what that means the
difference it will make
the survival rate for cancer at stage
one and two is 81 percent
but at stage three and four it's just 26
percent
what a difference that would make
and finally
killer three
suicide
last year I went to an event organized
by the band New Order
and they asked me
for obvious reasons given their history
did I know anyone
that's died in that way
I have to admit it took me a back I've
never been asked that certainly not in
public before
but you know
I didn't have to think that long
I do
more than one in fact
three friends
and if I asked everyone in this room
the same question
I guess you wouldn't have to think about
it for long either
suicide is the biggest killer of young
lives in this country
the biggest killer
that statistic should haunt us
and the rate is going up
our mission must be and will be to get
it down
so there's no time to do that this
Mission starts with people
that's at the height of the classes
right now that's why we've committed to
the biggest expansion of NHS training in
its history
all nurses doctors midwives and health
visitors all fully funded by removing
the non-dom tax status
it's why we'll leave no stone unturned
when it comes to finding new ways to cut
waiting lists labor has done it before
and will do it again
imagine that you're waiting for a knee
operation
and the waiting list isn't going down at
your local hospital
but in the trust next door they have a
specialist Orthopedic Center and things
are moving much more quickly
I say you should be able to go there
instead
I say there shouldn't be a separate
waiting list at this Hospital a separate
waiting list at that hospital hospitals
should work together
so I can announce today to cut waiting
lists more quickly patients should be
able to visit nearby hospitals when
faster treatment is available and labor
will give them that choice
and that's only the beginning
as I keep saying we've got to go beyond
the sticking plaster approach I talked
earlier about the light at the end of
the tunnel
the reward for reform
we've got to hold on to that and there
are grounds to be optimistic
but it will require three shifts shifts
which must place at the heart of
everything we do on health
shift one
we must move care away from hospitals
and closer to the community
the NHS must become a Neighborhood
Health Service
I'll put it bluntly at the moment we
aren't good enough at treating people
early in the community
we leave it to hospitals and quite often
that's too late
and if we change this it will save lives
and money
that's why we're going to improve GP
access in the 8am scramble
we'll trade more GPS but we'll also make
the future of general practice more
sustainable
as the contractor model declines in some
communities we won't let patients go
without the care that they need
so we'll bring fragmented Services
together and make sure salary GP serve
all communities
and will modernize the appointment
system
for those who want real continuity of
care will bring back the family doctor
that's what people with long-term
conditions need
but for those who just want a quick
appointment at their convenience who
want a digital consultation will give
those patients a different route
seriously it can't be Beyond us to offer
different options for different people
we've just got to roll up our sleeves
and get it done
and one more thing we've got to fix the
back door problem
we can't have hospitals blocked up by
patients who are desperate to go home
and ready to be discharged
so we'll make good on the integration of
Health and Social care
backing successful models like the
center at Bromley by Beau
where in one place they bring together
doctors nurses physiotherapists social
carers
to provide joined up care in the
community keeping people out of Hospital
and look we will recruit and retain more
carers with a fair pay agreement
this is fundamental
it's about who and what we respect
it's about better standards at work
about dignity more progression more
training more rights and yes about pay a
fair deal for our carers that's what
people clapped for
foreign
we must move from a mindset that views
Health as all about sickness to one
where we put prevention first right
across Society
so we'll take bold action where early
intervention can make a huge difference
on Mental Health
and make no mistake we intend to
revolutionize mental health treatment in
this country
8 500 new mental health professionals
specialist access in every school
guaranteed treatment inside four weeks
for anyone who needs it
and look the mission we're launching
today isn't just an NHS mission
it's a Health Mission
when we talk about a new deal for
working people on employment rights
about good work for all that's a health
policy
when we say We'll provide breakfast
clubs with healthy food for all primary
school children that's a health policy
when we commit to restoring a decent
home standard to regulating the water
industry to a new Clean Air Act they're
all Health policies
and when I say we will take on the
social media companies who push
dangerous misogyny on our children
I am saying very clearly to those who
profit from harming our children no
not in Britain
and today we go further on that
we will change advertising rules and we
will make sure that products which are
harmful to our children's health vaping
junk food sugary snacks cannot be
advertised to our children no
not in Britain
shift three technology a revolution that
will accelerate the first two shifts and
Herald a different kind of Health Care
a move from an analog to a digital NHS a
tomorrow service not just a today
service
and mark my words this can be
transformational
the route to the NHS offering shorter
waiting times better treatment early
diagnosis and meaningful prevention
Britain leaves the world in science and
technology we can make this happen this
is the game changer the light at the end
of the tunnel
this is what will make the NHS fit for
the future
I'll give an example
33 million people downloaded the NHS app
during the pandemic and it's a good app
but that extraordinary opportunity
it's been wasted
labor would take the app and Innovations
like it
we would deepen them expand them and put
them in the hands of patients
and use them to transform our
relationship with the NHS
get this right and it means moving to a
fully digital patient records never
again handwritten notes getting lost
it means booked appointments appropriate
self-referral routes remind us to get
checkups and screening the latest
guidance on treatment
patients in control of their own data
choosing how it's used and how it's
shared
this will get rid of a divide between
those confident to speak up for
themselves
and those who can't
and look if we make sure everyone is
supported
then we can take people on this journey
and it will mean people can get better
choices we'll get faster care can manage
their own health
in truth it's about politicians catching
up with the public and the NHS catching
up with the revolution that's already
happened in the rest of our lives
and it doesn't stop there
technology provides more choice and
Powerful patients but it also saves
lives
take artificial intelligence
AI will change the nature of healthcare
and Britain is good at AI
I'll give an example
lung cancer is the number one cause of
cancer-related deaths in the UK
274 000 patients waiting for 11 days or
more to hear back from the scan
which could tell them if they have
cancer
AI can reduce workload and raise
productivity but here's the real thing
when used properly by a radiologist
it can reduce missed lung cancer
diagnosis by 60 percent
and because it's quicker
because it's more accurate the lives it
could save through early diagnosis are
countless
but to make this happen innovators need
one route into the NHS not many
incentives to innovate throughout the
system
fewer barriers to adoption fewer hurdles
to clear less bureaucracy more clinical
trials and a government that uses its
full power to back our world-leading
life sciences
and look when you add this all together
the sum total of these three shifts
what you get is a plan a plan for a
future NHS that protects what is
precious and Embraces what is possible
from everyone waiting stuck on the call
at 8am
to a primary care system that offers
different choices for different needs
from long Waits at a e to hospitals that
carry a lighter load because more care
is in the community
an NHS where technology gives patients
more responsibility and professionals
more time
where we diagnose disease earlier
screen people in supermarkets libraries
Leisure centers communities
where we can save lives because Health
Care is closer to lives
and above all where the whole of society
contributes to the mission of healthier
happier longer lives
that's an ambition we can rally around a
goal that can lift the anxiety the pain
the fear faced by millions of families
across the country and replace it with
the hope of a renewed NHS
in place of fear that's what 199 Bevan
called his book
and if people want to call me dewey-eyed
want to say I'm a romantic about the
values of the NHS
I plead guilty
the NHS has played an enormous role in
my life
my mum was a nurse
proud nurse too
but she was also severely ill for most
of her life with a rare condition called
Stills disease
at the age of 11
she was told two things
one she would be in a wheelchair by her
twenties
two that she should forget about having
kids
now that diagnosis didn't reckon with my
mum's determination and courage
but it also didn't reckon with the NHS
a doctor at guys Hospital in London
refused to give up
he found an experimental treatment for
this 11 year old girl
and the rest
as they say it's history
honestly lots of people say they owe the
NHS everything and I'm definitely one of
them
but that's just the point
mum's story isn't special
behind every single door in this country
there is a family who will have their
own version
this is who we are the NHS belongs to
everyone
the foundation for the comfort security
health of working people
for 75 years and ever present in our
story family and Nation
my message today is simple
with labor the story continues we have a
plan
I want the patience of the future to
remember this moment remember the
changes we'll make together
that's our mission
we will fight for the NHS we will fix
the NHS we will reform the NHS old
values New Opportunities technology and
science convenience and control renewal
not decline an NHS not just off its
knees but running confidently towards
the future thank you very much
thank you
thank you very much
we're going to take some questions
starting with the media my list tells me
that Helen Kat from the BBC is first
Helen
wide-ranging reforms but you have said
that money does play A Part would you
expect under labor that overall more
money would be going into the NHS well
look money is important but it's not all
about money and what I'm sending out
today is that change and reform plays a
hugely important part and what I said
about technology is an important part of
that technology can be the revolution
technology can do what money can't do so
I accept that money is part of the
solution but change in reform is hugely
important the game changer is technology
is about what we can do in the future
that we can't do now and that is why
this mission is not just about getting
the anxious
up myself its knees my wife says on its
face and getting it standing up again
but actually creating an HS that's fit
for the future and that means harnessing
that technology and that change thank
you very much Helen let me find my list
I've got Liz Liz
hi Liz
hello Liz from Sky News uh just to
follow up on that it does seem like
you're trying to sort of Kick this issue
of money into the long grass a little
bit how do you expect the public to
trust you with the public finances if
you're not prepared to say quite
straightforwardly these are our plans
this is how much they will cost and this
is how we will pay for them if you don't
mind just very quickly on strikes and
striking workers some of them will be
watching this speech thinking oh you're
going to bring loads of new staff into
the NHS but you won't say how much
you're going to pay them
and you won't stand with them on the
picket lines these are the people that
you want to deliver your plans do you
have anything new to say to them today
well Liz look first of all let's just um
call the spade a spade where we've made
a proposal about the change we're going
to bring we've said how it's going to be
funded so this challenge you put to me
that we've not said where the money is
coming from is just wrong actually are
we going to have the biggest increase in
training for the NHS that it's ever had
in its history yes are we going to pay
for that by abolishing the non-dom tax
status yes are we going to have 8 500
more mental health advisors in our
communities yes are we going to pay for
it by closing the tax loophole for
private Equity yes so what we've been
careful to do is to say where we're
making changes what the change will be
and how we will pay for it but we have
to I think see that the change that can
be brought around through technology and
digital working data AI is going to be
trying transformational of course I know
that we've got to put more money in and
we've got to grow the economy but you
know what we're putting on the table is
the change that the NHS needs for the
future and as for the staff look I know
NHS staff pretty well my wife is one of
them
um so I get a diet a daily readout of
what is uppermost in their minds they
want to know they're fully supportive
they want to know they're they're
respected they want to know there's a
plan for the future because the one
thing that I've been struck by recently
is the number of people who are not just
worrying about appointments about
waiting lists about a e
under this government 13 years of
failure but now worried about whether
the NHS will continue to exist we've not
been in that place before and the staff
share that and when we say to them we're
going to have the biggest training
regime the NHS has ever had that the
Cavalry is coming that is very very
welcome to the staff who desperately
desperately need it thank you list at
shehab from ITV
news you talk about all these reforms
you talk about new technology that you
want to see introduced into the NHS but
all of that will cost money is there an
estimate of how much exactly this is
going to cost and how quickly can you
implement it and a second question if I
may you've spoken about NHS staff we
know that morale is particularly low at
the moment there are many who feel
they're overworked and underpaid how do
you bring them along with you on this
process of Reform and change if you're
not going to pay them more
um look on cost we have set out the
costing for our specific proposals in
terms what it will cost where we will
get the money from
technology research development they
will be the game changers of the future
and reduce costs if we go to a
preventative model it will make a huge
difference take cancer diagnosis it's
not just obviously better for patients
to be diagnosed earlier because you
heard the statistics about survival
rates it's also a reduction of cost
across the NHS merging waiting lists so
that you don't have to just wait for one
Hospital you go to different hospitals
will reduce the cost so you know I do
understand the challenge that you are
all putting to me but I have run a
public service I do know the stresses
and strained
public service but I also know having
run a public service for five years that
it's not all about cost that change and
reform is critically important and you
know if we just put more money in the
top of our Public Services we will get a
better outcome but we won't get a
materially better outcome unless we
change and reform that was my my lesson
from running a public service for five
years thank you shehab
um Chloe from the eye
you've announced plans for what you
describe as an ambitious reform of
healthcare but there's been little to no
detail about what you would do about
social care is that no longer a priority
and if it is when are we going to hear
about these plans yeah uh look it is a
priority because I think everybody
understands that
um the back door to the NHS Hospital
crisis is getting people out of care
into the community and that social care
is a big part of that answer what we
have set out on social care in clear
terms
is a plan for the staff for those who
work in the care sector and declare an
interest my sister is a care worker so I
know the sector pretty well there are
over a hundred thousand vacancies and we
have to fix that problem and I think the
only way we can fix that problem is by
having a framework for staff within
social care so that they have Fair pay
agreements so they have dignity and
respect so they can progress through on
a clear careers path which isn't there
at the moment I think it's one in three
people leaving social care are going
into the NHS and they're doing that
because there there's a better chance of
progression than there is in Social care
we've got to fix that I think we can
look at the roles that social care
workers can do the sorts of tasks that
they can do all of that is a big part of
what we need to do on social care and we
also I think need to have as a clear
principle a sort of home first principle
so that it starts with what can be
supported at home rather than simply
assuming that that can't be provided and
we've got to go elsewhere thank you
Chloe Sam from the Sun
thanks
um would you do anything to reform the
way that you decide how NHS staff are
paid the Royal College of Nursing is
still not happy with their pay offer so
what would you do about that going
forward and would you give a pay rise to
Consultants earning six figure salaries
um look on the structure of negotiations
um we haven't focused on that to be
frank because what I've set out today is
what we need to do to make sure the NHS
is fit for the future so we know that
you know a fair pay agreement Fair pay
isn't an essential part of that and I
would you know I think it was Saturday
just gone
this government has lasted as long as
the last Labor government and that gives
us a really good opportunity to compare
and contrast because under the last
Labor government nurses were paid fairly
there wasn't a national strike waiting
lists were down and satisfaction was at
a a record high compare that with what
we've got now where nobody really
quarrels with the proposition that after
13 years of failure the NHS is on its
knees the only debate we're having is it
is it on its knees or is it on its face
that is a shocking shocking Legacy thank
you Sam Aubry from the guardian
one of the main targets that you've set
out this morning is to reduce deaths
from heart disease by quarter in 10
years this morning on the radio you were
asked directly and said you wouldn't
support levying a salt or sugar tax
during the cost of living crisis but
when food prices return to normal levels
do you rule out full stop
or the the focus that we put today is
very clearly on Advertising this is
something the government toyed with and
then moved away from I think that showed
a fundamental weakness in their approach
an unseriousness about tackling the
issues that really matter what I don't
want to do in a cost of living crisis is
to add to the burden of food cost for
families that are struggling so that's
why I've been very clear about where the
focus is
um today why we're focusing on
advertising and this can be done very
simply and very easily we'll make a
material difference to predominantly the
children and young people involved into
their health but also have a significant
effect on the NHS itself
um Nick I think the Health Service
Journal
Nick hi I'm Nick catuna from the Health
Service Channel
um you've set up the plans for improving
performance in the NHS but under Blair
one of the key centers of that was
strong NHS management
um in terms of where do you go forward
from here do you think that we need more
managers just as men just as much as we
need doctors and nurses to get the NHS
back to where it is and a very quick
second question the capital program set
up by the government it do you plan to
carry that on to the new hospitals
program under labor
thank you thank you very much on the
question of
um the staff the workforce of the NHS my
message is clear first thank you
you are the light at the end of the
tunnel and we wouldn't have it without
you
um secondly there's got to be changed
and everybody will have to step up so I
don't think it's a question of
distinguishing I actually think that
um most of the reforms that we want to
carry out will be front line it'll be at
that prevention stage the diagnosis
stage and so it'll be very front line
LED but you know everybody across the
NHS in order to sustain the NHS we'll
have to be part of that change and
reform on new hospitals look I mean it's
hard to say we'll continue a plan which
isn't really a plan because these 40
hospitals are pretty mythical
um but look I don't dispute that
um you know infrastructure and
structures are hugely important in all
of this everybody everywhere will have a
story of hospitals that
um you know have all sorts of
difficulties because they've not been
properly maintained and of course we
will have we will inherit that and we
will have to deal with that I do think
our argument that the burden on
hospitals should be lightened with more
care in the community is hugely
important to this because you know at
the moment there's earlier stepping
stone between the local GP and going to
a hospital and we have to close that Gap
so yes it's a problem we will inherit no
I don't think the government's got a
real plan it was another thing that was
said but will not be done we will
inherit that of course but our plan goes
beyond that question into the way care
will be provided under a future model to
make the NHS not something that we just
reflect on with pride but actually is
there for the next 75 years in the way
it's been there for the last 75. thank
you Nick I've got Sophie from the mirror
in the mirror so you mentioned in your
speech about black women being four
times more likely to die during
childbirth we obviously see these Health
inequalities across the board with staff
too with minority ethnic doctors being
less likely to get specialist NHS
training would you say that the Health
Service is institutionally racist you
also say that you'll root out these
inequalities but can you say actually
how you'll do that uh yeah look I'm not
I'm not here to denigrate the Health
Service and actually
um my point was really to highlight the
inequalities and I I think that
statistic about black women dying
um you know when having a baby is is
very arresting and I think nobody can
listen to that and not have instilled in
them a real sense that things have got
to change so wherever it is it's got to
change but inequality is a big part of
the Health Challenge and I don't think
it's possible to solve the Health
Challenge if we don't tackle at the same
time the inequality challenge so thank
you very much Sophie Nick from the
telegraph nick uh thank you to um to
come back to the money if I may you've
said the NHS is underfunded and that you
are going to put more money in health
spending is a proportion of government
spending has risen very rapidly over the
last couple of decades it's now at about
22 percent and that has obviously come
by spending Less proportionally in other
areas
you think that number's too low and how
high would you be prepared to see that
go 25 30
and on the same theme you know you've
made sort of great play of balancing the
books so when you do come up with
proposals in the future for how you're
going to pay with all this would you be
straight that it's going to be either
tax Rises or spending cuts in other
areas uh Nick firstly on the money
that's already going into the NHS
it needs to be used as effectively and
efficiently as we can and among my
frustrations with the annual NHS winter
crisis
is that the sticking plaster the bit
that comes in January February comes
with a huge price usually too late to
make it as effective as it could be and
therefore
simply the using the money that's going
in more effectively will make a huge
difference there are plenty of other
examples when it comes to early
diagnosis screening preventative
measures
Etc on your challenge as will we set out
in terms what we will spend and where
we'll get the money from then yes as you
will have seen there's a pattern here
under labor which is where we say we're
going to do something we set out what
it's going to do and then we say where
the money will come from we will
continue in that vein but I can't
emphasize enough that
simply believing that everything is
about money and not about change in
reform I think is to look at this in the
wrong way I think that change in reform
technology
AI these are going to transform
Healthcare in the future and reduce the
cost along the way and we've got to
approach the next 75 years the next
generation of healthcare with that very
firmly in mind thank you Nick I've got
Russell from Anglia Russell Hi there
yeah I appreciate you've touched on
infrastructure a little there but you've
come here to the east of England to
outline your plans and your vision for
the NHS the east of England has many uh
NHS buildings which have reached the end
of their life including the hospital in
King's Lynn where of 3 000 props holding
up the roof we've got crumbling roofs at
the West Suffolk Hospital in berries and
Edmonds it is your ambition to keep
people out of hospital but many will
still end up there how much have you
factored in the cost of renewing the NHS
estate in your plans and will that
involve public private Finance
initiatives or are you trying to avoid
locking hospitals into those uh Russell
firstly let me acknowledge the premise
of your question which is
um that the east of England has real
challenges when it comes to hospitals
also I think in terms of GP
accessibility in some parts of the east
of England so there's a real challenge
here and yes of course we've got to deal
with the infrastructure the state of our
hospitals is unacceptable in the east of
England or anywhere across uh England so
we will have to deal with that my speech
our plans today
are or include the future of healthcare
generally so you know will we have to
deal with the terrible Legacy that we
will inherit if we're privileged enough
to come into power yes we will will we
have to fix the problems yes we will I
don't shy away from that but if all we
aspire to do as an incoming labor
government is to fix the problems and
put the NHS back where it was before 13
years of failure then I don't think
that's ambitious enough which is why
we've gone Way Beyond that today thank
you Russell and I think we've got Ben
from BBC look East yeah from the BBC in
the East um changing tanks slightly you
said you came to Braintree because labor
was on the march in Essex but in Harlem
the party went backwards sportswear in
our region you had been bullish about
taking Great Yarmouth Council but failed
to do that and I
local authorities the greens are now the
why do you think labor underperformed at
the local elections earlier this month
and how much responsibility do you take
for that well Ben thank you very much
for that challenge I think you put a
version of that challenge to me last
year after local elections as well and
quite right to what I would say is this
um three years and a couple of months
ago I took over as leader of the labor
party and as Wes was saying in his
introductory remarks that was a labor
party that just lost an election the
worst loss we'd had since 1935. many
people thought it was impossible to go
from there to even talking about a labor
majority government now the challenge
I'm getting is
um you know how are you gonna actually
set up that labor majority government
what are you going to do in government
I'm pleased to take that we did make
progress here in the east of England we
did make progress in the places you
mentioned but we've got to do more and
I've said to my shadow cabinet we've got
step up again the trajectory we're on is
a trajectory that takes us to a majority
labor government and I'm very pleased
about that and that's not just about
numbers if you look I mean we're talking
today about the NHS but if you look
across the country the sort of
overwhelming conclusion pretty well now
is almost everything is broken and
nobody feels better off now than they
did 13 years ago that is the scale of
the challenge and we need a majority
labor government to get there that means
we've got to earn every vote including
in the east of England including in the
places that you mentioned I'm determined
that we will continue to do that but the
the progression in the labor party from
where we started to where we are has
been very very significant and most
people when I took over as leader-led
party shook me by the hand and said good
luck and then an ex-breath said it's not
possible to get from where you are to a
labor government in one parliamentary
term I've never accepted that I don't
accept it now and we will march to go
back to my opening words on
um here in Braintree and the east of
England as we will across the whole of
the United Kingdom thank you all very
much indeed thank you thank you
lately their Kia Style with their
pledging to tackle Cancer and a and e
waiting times uh making a big speech
there about the NHS he says that he
wants to get the NHS off its knees by
tackling waiting lists and deaths from
heart disease and strokes uh also
committing to hit for our A and E
targets which haven't been achieved
nationally since 2015 and ambulance
response times hitting all of those
targets by around 20 20